entre deux jeunes enfants est une petite
entreprise c'était si lapierre avait
besoin de vacances
la maman de nouvelle écosse pensait
avoir trouvé l'endroit parfait pour un
séjour avec des amis à montréal en avril
et loue un loft au centre ville sur le
compte d'al j lo travay 4 étoiles et
beaucoup de bonnes critiques mais une
fois sur place
en juillet c'était dégueulasse dit
lapierre les femmes découvrent des
planchers salle de la moisissure dans la
salle de bain des matelas
rongé par les souris elle retourne sur
le profil de son hôte
aj et à tout un choc elle découvre des
centaines de commentaires négatifs
airbnb avait retiré ses annonces au
moins depuis juin mais plusieurs clients
qui avaient déjà réservé des mois al
avance pour un séjour en pleine saison
touristique nous disent qu'ils n'ont
jamais été mises au courant c'était si
la pierre est furieuse et le résultant
d'annuler et de ravoir son argent maliba
andré caron a été plus chanceux il a
annulé sa réservation avec aj avant son
séjour il a découvert la même propriété
sur un nouveau compte
ouais mais je pense que c'était est
assez surveillé si quelqu'un capable
un hoax offert avec les mêmes photos les
mêmes
ces mêmes humains dommage radio-canada a
retrouvé 45 annonce d'agir sur ce
nouveau conte celui de berry quelques
jours après nos appels a agi berry et
l'accompagné airbnb les deux cantons
étaient complètement retirée du site
la mairesse de montréal craint qu'à la
longue ces mauvaises expériences auront
un impact sur la réputation de la ville
alors moi même comme maman qui voyage
qu'ils valent et j'espère que mes
enfants je me suis imaginé arriver
devant une adresse qui n'existent pas où
ça doit éthérée donc ça la salle un
impact sur la la réputation montréal où
l'expérience de montréal
tu n'as plus fort bien des affirme
qu'elle a retiré les deux comptes parce
qu'il violait les règlements
d'utilisation de sa plateforme
elle dit aussi que les voyageurs qui ont
encore des réservations en cours seront
complètement remboursé mais la
plateforme ne nous a jamais préciser
pourquoi ces clients n'avaient pas été
avisés avant et si valérie wallet radio
canada toronto